hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so like i said in my amc
video that i posted yesterday guys i'm
gonna be moving this week i go back to
france after seven years six point five
years in hong kong i'm gonna stay a bit
in france then i'm not sure probably
dubai then miami i don't know yet but
whatever the thing is that i'm not gonna
be able to do any update during the
weekend so this is the last update of
the week and the next update is gonna be
done around the second or the third of
december just for you to know so let's
analyze everything that happened after
this huge breakout and re-test and see
what can happen next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so here is the situation
let me sum up a bit uh what happened in
the past week
so we have this huge triangle just like
we have on amc and we had the breakout
is it a breakout so let's check let's
check if this breakout is valid or not
so for breakout to be valid what we want
to see is some consolidation before
ideally we want to close above the upper
band of the bollinger band and we want
to have some volume so first thing when
we go across those levels so here and
here we had two strong days plus eight
plus eight i was updating you guys here
and i was saying if we close above 230
we are looking
amazingly good i was also saying that
i'm not sure if we're gonna get rejected
first or go to 250 and then get rejected
the second scenario happened i
personally like i said bought some puts
here i didn't increase my position by
buying more puts on the upside because
you know when it that bullish you don't
want to buy puts and i just exit my put
position around the same level about it
so
i'm back with my original position
and i'm very happy about it and right
now the situation is that we had this
two strong days so yeah we were checking
the volume guys and look bam the volume
is big big and the day we move lower so
we did minus 13 all right and the
previous two days was plus eight plus
eight
but look at the volume so we went
through a wider range of price action a
bigger range of price action uh on the
bearish day but the volume is smaller
than uh the second day and roughly the
same a bit higher than the first day so
this is rather good and then the volume
of the last day is even lower but
nothing much happened here so what is
the situation guys so the situation is
that we had the breakout it has been
confirmed we closed above totally which
was the recent high but like i said we
have some noise created by this candle
here that only traded a few hours
uh and this is the reason why i believed
we would go through this on that day
when i saw them stop training at 2 50 i
was like all right we are doing it right
now we are we're going there we didn't
you know it uh it's like that we got
rejected and this was kind of expected
you can check my previous video this was
my second scenario but the truth is that
even when i was looking at it i was
feeling like we are doing it right right
now it didn't happen this three hours
resistance level because we only spent
three hours even less one hour there
around the 250 level got us rejected and
we got back to the resistance trend line
that is at uh right now 220 so whenever
we do that we do that to take back some
energy you can check the rsi overbought
here overbought here so you know it's
just the market needs more energy how
can you assess the energy another way so
you can check the rsi you can also check
the bollinger bands
so here let's see if this breakout is
valid so here for example you see the
titans very well i'm looking more and
more at those bollinger bands so you're
going to see them more and more on my
chart because they are actually very
helpful to identify consolidation
periods i was before that doing it
visually but why would i keep doing that
visually when i have a beautiful tool
that is doing it for me so here we we
can see that this was a nice breakout so
it was a short-term breakout that i gave
you by the way and here as well guys we
closed above so on that day it was i
mean we had all the positive signals
only here the bollinger bands were a bit
wide because of this noise this is the
reason why we don't like to see some
noise before a breakout because
it creates some resistance level first
and it creates also more volatility in
the price so it can go on both sides it
can go on the upside onto that sound
like we had here basically when the
buddhist bands are wide everything can
pretty much happen so
this is the situation so right now what
is my view
so my view is that the breakout happened
the booze and control in the long term
they know that they can take control but
they suffered uh you know some losses
here i was personally not buying in that
move up but i could have be a buyer
there and if i was i know that right now
you don't feel great right you feel like
oh i shouldn't have fomo and you know
booze are a bit feeling like this right
now so i think we need a bit more time
ideally we need to stay above the 20-day
moving average right now at 209 because
this is uh usually what is supporting
the price during the strong moves up so
as long as we're above that level we
have the momentum with us let's check in
the past how it happened okay so you can
see here in the first move up in
september 20 it was acting very well
then here it got broken and then once
it's broken we needed like roughly two
weeks even more before going really high
we we needed one month all right so once
it's broken here's something broken then
three weeks
and then he broken and even longer one
month so basically once this 20-day
moving average is broken after we
started to move up in the past we can
see that we usually need two weeks one
month to recover and start to be really
bullish again so this is the reason why
i don't want it to see broken i would
like the price action to close above
that every day
if this happens of course it would be
very good for the coming week if it
doesn't happen then the alternative
scenario so let's finish on the first
scenario so this time if we go again to
250
like 80 percent probability for me
that it doesn't hold and if it doesn't
hold look at that guys so we're gonna
check quickly the shorts but especially
i want to show you what we have on the
300 strike all right because
this is the reason why
if we break 250
we go to to 350 for me okay because the
300 strike is absolutely massive
you can see it's uh almost twice as big
as the 250 strike which is the first
strike just above us right so this is
unusual on amc we don't have that on amc
the biggest strike is the 40 strikes on
gamestop this is more bullish let's be
honest than amc and if we break 250
we're probably gonna go quickly to 300
and if we come close to 300 we're gonna
go to 350. so my scenario is that either
we ride away bounce back okay doing
something like this okay then correct
this collection is a bit too deep maybe
something more like this so first
scenario and if this happens i would
personally be once again i have some
calls i would be buying puts this is the
best thing not to you know you don't
touch your upside performance you you
don't modify it by buying puts you just
by puts which you can sell lower later
so this is i think a good thing that
you can do to take some profits on the
way up without touching your upside
performance if
gamestop just goes to 800 right away you
will make roughly the same amount of
money as if you don't buy those puts
because the position disappears on the
upside so i would be personally buying
some puts around 350 that i would
probably try to take profit around 250
but i would not not do anything on the
way up
and the alternative scenario
is that unfortunately we break this
we find more support here we consolidate
i don't know for how long and then we do
this strong move up okay
so
we can go even a bit lower we have the
200 day moving average that is coming
right now at 1
82 guys so this is a very strong support
uh so this is alternative scenarios that
once again we break it and in this
situation it would take probably at
least two weeks one month before we
start to move higher again
so let's find out what is going to
happen let me just finish on the 950
strike i want to monitor that level with
you guys just like i'm doing with amc
145 strike okay bam where is it
okay so the 955 strike is here
so last time we had uh 4.1 million we
are at 4.17 so
4.17 million uh shares equivalent shares
on this strike so once again this is a
sign of bullishness this is something
i'm gonna keep an eye on
so that's it for me let me just recap
what is the situation the preferred
scenario is that we find support at uh
this level here on this trend line so we
might be drifting a little bit lower
it's fine we need just to stay above
this 20-day moving average that is right
now at 209 if this happens the bullish
momentum is still with us we're probably
going to go to 250 break this time go to
350 this is my preferred scenario
otherwise we might take one more month
and see what is happening later but i'm
pretty sure that we're gonna have a
strong support around the 200-day moving
average so that's it for today i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're gonna
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show i'll
see you guys